[Musique]
de retour au stade maoboran pour la
Coupe de France le FC Versailles qui
évolue en National avait à cœur de
gagner contre fleur 91 devant les 1000
spectateur présent pour ce 6e tour en
première période les Versaillais
dominent et poussent mais n'arrivent pas
à trouver la faille malgré la division
d'écart le score à la pause 0 à0 je
pense qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup
d'occasions voil sauf que il faut qu'on
arrive à les mettre au fond être plus
juste à concrétiser le nombre incroyable
qu'on a eu de situation pour être dans
une scénario plus confortable au retour
des vestiaires versaill attaque se
procure des occasions et marque enfin la
69e minute par l'International haïtien
mondiprunier 1 à0 mais l'avantage sera
de courte durée 4 minutes plus tard
Fleury égalis suite à cette tête de
Freddy Colombo un partout malgré
plusieurs opportunités et un but refusé
pour les joueurs de la cité royale le
score n'évoluera pas direction la séance
de tir au but dans cet exercice ce sont
les essoniens qui l'emportent 5 à 4
versaill demi-finaliste de la Coupe de
France en 2022 sort dès le 6e tour je
suis très agacé parce
que c'est un scénario qui se répète
depuis 4 C matchs au niveau de
l'ouverture de score sur ce match là on
a raté beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de situation voilà on doit être
beaucoup plus efficace dans tout ce
qu'on fait en ce moment donc faut se
taire et et se mettre à Bousser et avoir
une exigence un peu plus importante le
FC Versailles devra se replonger
rapidement dans le quotidien du
championnat de National les iinois 9e du
classement joueront dès ce vendredi 3
novembre à 19h30 sur le terrain de
Dijon